I believe that Hubbard is the ultimate
cult leader the ultimate guy who figured
out how you can persuade people to do
things that are against their best
interest and in his best interest
people do a lot of stuff in Scientology
you know my book is about my personal
experiences and the crazy insane things
that I did and the willingness to put up
with the most outrageous stuff that
happened to me and keep going but
scientologists all over the world
mortgage their houses and give away
their college funds and do all this
stuff that is not in their best
interests because they believe that
Scientology is in their best interest
and that trumps everything I had a I had
an agent of mine who uh her and her
husband they were making 250 a year
between their two jobs French
and when I would do their needs analysis
on their finances I would say how come
you guys are so broke
what is where does this money go to he
says oh you don't even know what we're
doing I said what are you doing we spent
fifty thousand dollars last year on this
course we spend this much money on this
I said why do you know what we're
learning with this you should take this
course I said how much money do you guys
spend every year in your church the
number they were telling me made like it
may and by the way it's not like they
were making a quarter million dollars
because they just started making a
quarter million dollars he was an
engineer he was a smart guy so the
question then becomes the following this
is where it gets a little bit confusing
one who was the a lot of times for a
person to who speaks like that big of
themselves and what they're going to be
doing there has to be the first True
Believer with credibility that validates
them right if you don't have a True
Believer with credibility that validates
them this could be anybody that's
talking a big game so who was the first
person that was a True Believer in him
that validated his teaching and
dianetics
well there was a um an editor that he
had had uh John W Campbell when he was
writing science fiction and he was
pretty influential in the publishing
circles at the time and he was one of
the early proponents along with this uh
medical doctor called Dr winter I can't
remember his first name and winter was
like the endorser of Dianetics for
Hubbard to begin with but shortly
thereafter he became like I'm going to
expose what's really going on here
because this is a bunch of [ __ ] but
he he quickly with dianetics
uh and through the publishing of the
book it became like a fad
like in the very very early days of
dinetics in the in the 1950s it was like
a fad and Hubbard would go around doing
lectures he did this famous lecture in
Los Angeles at The Shrine Auditorium and
he filled the place in 1950.
on the basis of the book and people like
oh my God this is the this is the answer
to everything and you know there is a
story that is told about
the claims that Hubbard made about what
a clear is and that is the ultimate goal
of Dianetics to rid yourself of your
reactive mind and you will then become
what's known as a clear and he made all
these claims about clears that they
would have basically a photographic
memory and have perfect computation and
because all of the the reactive mind was
removed so it just left the perfect
analytical mind and he got up on stage
and had someone who supposedly was clear
up there and they couldn't remember what
they had for breakfast or couldn't
remember what color tie he was wearing
when he turned around and this sort of
started the maybe there is not maybe
this isn't all that people believe it to
be and that began a long history of
habit
this is one of the other things of of
Dynex and Scientology when the claims
that he made would prove to be untrue he
would come up with a new part a new
thing ah yes well I'm I've been doing
more research and I've discovered now
that X Y and Z so we're going to do this
now we're not doing that anymore we're
doing this now and there is this
progression of things from 1950 all the
way up to the day he died of here is the
new hope
to attain what I've been promising you
could attain since day one
and the fact that people continue to buy
that or continue to buy that
for years and years and years is one of
the other sort of mysteries of how do
you get someone to
I mean it's it's like the apocalyptic
the end of the world is coming on the
17th of July you know
1934 and then on the 17th of July
there's no Armageddon and on the 18th of
July they're saying well we were just
getting ourselves prepared this was a
test God was testing us to see the
effective thing to do though a lot of
people have done that and they've
imposed a lot of fear and control over
people absolutely and the fear that
Scientology
or Hubbard presented to his followers is
the fear that you will have an eternity
of black hopelessness
without Scientology
the not only this planet but every being
in this universe is doomed doomed to a
dark black dwindling spiral of
nothingness and turning into a black
rock and it's like the heaven and hell
you've got on one hand ultimate
spiritual salvation freedom and
happiness and on the other hand ultimate
Blackness darkness and terrible terrible
fate awaiting you and the only
difference between the two is the
technology of elrond Hubbard which is
the only thing that can save the
Blackness and turn it into light and
that is the story of every religion on
planet Earth since day one and
Scientology is no different in that
respect the different the difference
with Scientology is it's presented and
sold as
you can have that
Pathway to spiritual freedom and
Enlightenment in the here and now
because we do things right now with
provided you pay right now with you that
give you the the first steps toward
accomplishing that ultimate objective
and take you all the way up the Hubbard
bridge to total freedom so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign
[Music]